avisent les on s'aime on profite du
paysage et de l'imposante basilique près
d'un million de touristes seront ici
chaque année
la préfecture a installé ses bornes de
sécurité pour qu'il puisse marcher plus
librement
elles sont discrètes mais les visiteurs
apprécient c'est sécurisant pour les
piétons ça laisse plus de latitude aux
piétons pour flâner sans avoir le souci
d'avoir un véhicule derrière ces faits
ce groupe
et puis de se faire faucher on vient de
bretagne on a l'habitude d'aller au mont
saint michel par exemple mais au moins
ça mais chalon se sentait moins en
sécurité
comme toute étape de pèlerinage mais
elle représente aujourd'hui un site
menacé par d'éventuelles attaques
terroristes
ce qui n'a pas dissuadé les touristes
étrangers la sécurité c'est quelque
chose qui nous préoccupe et tous avant
de venir mais finalement ici et tout va
bien on se sent en sécurité
ces bornes les voici dix comme celle ci
en cercle désormais le bourg du village
elles limitent l'accès aux voitures et
complète un dispositif de sécurité déjà
mis en place par la préfecture
ils vont être régulée en fonction de la
fréquentation et des horaires de cette
fréquentation et ce sont des bornes qui
vont sortir du sol qui vont donc être
activé par ses pôtes les lumineux que
l'on voit la grâce à des télécommandes
et à un système d'horloge électronique
n'est pas là pour ne pas avoir un
déploiement de forces de l'ordre
c'est extrêmement discret mais c'est
très efficace on le complète par des
dispositifs passifs les bornes qui
permet de réguler et de faire des des
enceintes de protection très très souple
on va le faire avec des quais de la
vision protection qui nous permet de
savoir exactement ce qui se passe et de
faire la police judiciaire c'est un
dispositif complet avec ses bornes
vézelay fait partie d opération grand
site mis en place par l'état
il s'agit d'une surveillance privilégié
pas uniquement pour les touristes mais
aussi pour la communauté jésuite qui
réside ici à l'année
ces bornes sont discrètes et
réel mais discrète et donc du coup ça
n'est pas ostentatoire et ça c'est
important
on nous mettrait un grand panneau
vigipirate à l'entrée de la basilique ça
me gênerait beaucoup mais là une borne
ça canalise la circulation vers l'est
devrait rester le premier site
touristique gratuit le plus fréquenté en
bourgogne en 2018
la sécurité sera renforcée avec des
caméras de vidéosurveillance